you'd have one superpower what would you
pick baby backside how'd you know my
name say my name so my powers may throw
them
you can switch by shake Suzanne this
crazy punch charge your phone stars you
have immunity bulletproof
you're dead like a bad guy right
only I have the power unleashed wait
what you will beg for mercy are you
making some buy biggie evil guys speech
right now or something you're like a
mile away from me while I see its mouth
moving as I feast on your heart
Oh whatever screw it who are you
I can't doctor fish what could we do
with that that's cool maybe a commander
an army of billions in the ocean oh yeah
everybody is Charlie we got a brand new
Shazam trailer with a whole bunch of new
footage and they just declared open
season on all the Justice League
characters talk to fish what kind of
cool stuff could we do with that oh I
don't know maybe summon an army of fish
as he tugs on his Jason Momoa symbol
Aquaman t-shirt so we'll break down all
the references there's a bunch of cool
stuff here too you get a much better
look at the rock of eternity so I'll
talk a little bit about that because it
is different during the new 52 but the
movie is sort of a blend of newer new 52
things in the classic Shazam comics
we're still doing an IMAX take a
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video uh name a new winner at the
end of this but it starts out with a
much wider shot of Billy entering the
rock of eternity the wizard explaining
things to him without really explaining
anything to him because he leaves
without knowing how to use any of them
the wizard is basically like here I'm
giving you my power because I think that
you're worthy and that's about the gist
of it he kind of figures it out as he
goes along and that's part of the fun of
the movie so that by the time we get to
a sequel he'll know a little bit more
but he'll always be learning new things
about the ways that his powers work in
ways that he can use his abilities as
you see the wizard sitting on his chair
there you see all these empty ones
that's a really cool black atom Easter
Egg for the new 52 comics so if you're
not familiar with the mythology of
Shazam or how it's changed over time
because they did change it during the
new 52 in the classic comics the
original acronym Shazam stood for wisdom
of Solomon strength of Hercules stamina
of Atlas power of Zeus courage of
Achilles and speed of mercury and those
just represented the different types of
abilities that he could summon in battle
but during the new 52 they changed who
some of those gods were so you may have
seen this picture of the Shazam gods
they're basically the other wizards that
sit on the magical council that sort of
governed the world in lay judgment on
people that misuse magic or misuse
magical artifacts to hurt people as of
the new 52 the rock of eternity was near
conduct and that's where they formed
their council their very first act was
to condemn Pandora a la Pandora's box so
then after that sometime he christened
Black Adam as his successor things went
completely sideways and black Adam
killed
all the other mythological gods except
for the wizard as of the new 52 the
different letters of the acronym
represents slightly different powers and
different gods it goes strength of Siva
who's one of the old gods of New Genesis
remember new gods Jack Kirby fourth
world he's one of the old gods that died
off a long time ago and I'm probably
gonna mispronounce this name but it's
the fires of Ron Muir who's the Martian
god of death the compassion of an
appalling god of reincarnation the
source manipulation of zaw news that's
what the Z stands for he's actually the
father of Darkseid the boldness of @a
she's the goddess of impulses as in the
impulse to do things then the last one
is the lightning of Mamre Gann who is
the wizard Shazam or originally known as
Shazam he actually has a real name his
name is mamrie Gann but nobody calls him
that so the reason why all these chairs
have been empty for eons is because
black Adam killed all the others so
maybe there'll be some kind of offhanded
reference to that in the movie or
they'll pay that off when we get to the
Black Adam movie I've already talked
about that too because we did get some
details on the Black Adam movie
preliminary so that could change in the
future you get a longer scene of freddy
freeman and billy in their bedroom
figuring out that he can switch powers
on and off by saying the word Shazam he
learns that he can fly in front of that
giant crowd of people after dr. sivana
rolls up to challenge him there's a
couple scenes where he tries to fly like
there's one where he's midair falling
screaming Superman's name Superman
Superman which arm is it just going
crazy
there's another scene where he and
Freddie Freeman talk about him leaping
tall buildings like Superman there's the
other scene where he tries to jump
really high and accidentally jumps in
the high-rise window saying sorry sorry
everybody there's a much more polished
version of the scene in the park where
he uses his super speed to save this
woman from the Creepo
she asked him what's your name and it
seems like a completely separate scene
from the funny moment at the convenience
store after the big robbery say where
Freddie Freeman tells the girl his
name's captain sparkle fingers so maybe
this moment is a little more genuine and
he just fumbles his way into telling her
my name is Shazam you get a much longer
brand-new scene of their battle midair
in downtown Philly dr. sivana is
wielding the Wizards staff so this is
probably a little bit later in the film
he goes on starts villain monologuing
they played really serious Zachary Levi
has this really funny Express
on his face like it's a little kid
trying to look fearsome but it's meant
to be really cringey and funny and it's
meant to be that way on purpose the
movie is very self-aware in that way so
if it comes off as kind of cheesy and
funny like they're actually going for
that in some of these moments it's all
meant to be a joke on Superman versus
Zod during Man of Steel when they're
flying around midair and Zod starts
monologuing and Superman is listening to
him now he has super hearing but in this
moment I guess Billy hasn't figured out
how to do that so he just starts waving
his hands please stop talking just you
know whatever fine I'll just rush at you
because I can't hear anything that
you're saying the zooming on Billy's
face where he actually looks really
afraid on the steps to the museum these
are actually the steps to the
Philadelphia Museum where you see rocky
in all those movies this could be part
of that busking scene where he's
throwing lightning then realizes that
he's just destroyed the buses tire and
it flies off the overpass or it could be
when dr. sivana rolls up there's a
really nice shot of dr. sivana throwing
magical lightning while they're flying
at Billy destroying famous Philadelphia
monuments I think this is a statue of
Benjamin Franklin and they're just going
for a Ben Franklin lightening reference
then you get one of the biggest Batman V
Superman jokes that I've seen in any of
these movies and there are a lot of
Batman and Superman jokes about the
other DC movies there's a little kid
playing with his Batman and Superman
action figures humming the John Williams
Superman theme making them clash midair
while Billy in dr. sivana clash midair
outside his apartment window just like
Superman and Zod during Man of Steel so
it's almost like the exact same fight
sequence that you would get during Man
of Steel from a very very different
perspective with a very different tone
sort of poking fun at a lot of these
superhero tropes but the director
actually did clarify that some of this
will not make it into the final cut of
the movie so they've been screening the
movie for critics so far all the
reactions have been really positive it
says a lot that Warner Brothers is
screening the movie this early for
critics and letting them talk about it
so if you're worried about Shazam it
sounds like it's gonna do gangbusters at
least Wonder Woman numbers in terms of
worldwide box office then after their
epic Batman V Superman joke they have
the mother of all Aquaman trolls talking
to fish he's looking at the little
fishbowl what cool things can we do with
that and if you're Freddie Freeman's
trying to tell him about Aquaman oh I
don't know summon an army of fish the
the aquaman movie justified that is that
he can talk to fish on a really local
level like one at a time maybe like a
small group of fish it's when he gets
the Trident of Poseidon that connects
into all aquatic life all over the
planet at the same time so that's when
he's able to summon the massive army of
aquatic life he's also able to command
the careth in although I think that's a
little bit more of a partnership because
she's so powerful that I think she just
agrees to help him out
[Music]
but a lot of that so lead to the Aquaman
sequel I'm sure that they'll find cool
new ways for him to use his abilities
during the sequel because there's still
a lot of stuff that they haven't got in
that first movie was really just dealing
with his basic power set but as for
Justice League references I think that
we've gotten some flash references
recently in the only big Wonder Woman
reference that I've seen in any of the
Shazam clips recently is when they're in
the toy store for that funny Batman Joe
get him Batman
and you see all the toys for the Justice
League characters including cyborg of
all people there's really only the
beginning there's so much of the other
DC movies laid into this and they don't
make too much fun of them and like I
said not all those scenes that you see
in the trailers will make it into the
final cut of the movie so what'll happen
is is I'll actually be seeing the movie
a couple of different times in the next
couple weeks so I'll find out when I'm
allowed to post my full review video and
obviously I'll do a non-spoilery review
just like I would do for any other movie
then once the movie hits theaters will
do Easter eggs post credits and talk
about potential sequels Justice League
crossover in the future all that really
good stuff if you have any special
Shazam or DC movie requests let me know
in the comments below big news - they
just cast Deathstroke for Titan season 2
I might do a separate video about that
this week but do not forget what is
probably gonna happen the week that
Shazam comes out is that they'll put
tickets for Avengers end game on sale
and release the next big Avengers
trailer Marvel does that all the time
when DC has big things that it drops
it'll drop a new trailer for whatever
big movie is coming out just like oh
yeah by the way we have this giant movie
that's coming out at the end of April
here you go here's a whole bunch of new
footage to freak out over there was a
trailer that they screened recently at a
Disney investors meeting with a bunch of
Captain Marvel scenes I've already done
a breakdown video that I'll link it at
the end of this congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big video
Keith Pavan please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details click here for that breakdown of
the New Avengers and game trailer and
click here for this week's flash episode
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you